[Music]
in [ __ ] your funs news oh [ __ ] them up
submitted by chicken blood Oh bummer
coagulated Deena gwaan a hospital
refuses a donation from men who wore
sexy nurse outfits to raise money and
then they don't want that gay blood
that's stupid I love men who are so
comfortable with their sexuality they
can dress the best girls and I do get
[ __ ] so then Bart and Joe must be your
face yeah I love people like that cuz I
like any guy who says like no that's gay
I can never do that that's when I like
then you're really gay yeah yeah that's
when I really be like you're a [ __ ] yep
because if you're afraid okay that means
you are or your [ __ ] oh you have such
little like confidence in your sexuality
I'll give a guy a [ __ ] for free just
to show you how mad I am some manly we
gotta talk babe I don't know what the
standards are for men these days so for
you it's only like if it's jokingly
doing it or what if you're just walking
and my boyfriend he's just wearing a
girl's though or your stuff my friend my
friend finger my [ __ ] I'm not gay but
of course there's like a certain type of
Fenneman feminine but I can't date like
I dated a male model once couldn't do it
you mean like a fashion model he was
like a beautiful fashion model hapa he
was beautiful it's like back when I was
younger and I remember like sleep when I
came I wake up and I was like wow man he
even sleeps pretty you back it was
[ __ ] beautiful but then like were you
just jealous like man you can't be more
prettier than me [ __ ] that it took so
long for him to get ready every time I
go out shut up bad ass serious man like
hair like 17 different hair Potter I
don't even know what it means to get
ready to go out sometimes I just walk
out yeah first teeth wash knees put
clothes on yeah put clothes on the other
stuff is optional yeah
putting clothes on yeah sometimes like
when I take pictures with fans I'm like
you know I should look a little bit
better because my hair is like all
[ __ ] up like I just woke up it's all
pressed that one side I just grabbed the
shirt that I wore the other day with dog
fur all over it
I got like shorts on that had chalk all
over my like shorts because I like
probably worked out the other day and
like went like this and there's like a
mustard stain and I'm just wearing my
sandals and I got my hairy [ __ ] yeah
I probably had the worst pant approach
ever this was last year and I was still
living in k-town
you remember that blood facial that I
did yeah oh yeah it's basically like
getting thousands of tattoo needles in
your face it was super red with blood so
my face looked like I was skinned like I
was red and I was waiting for a parking
spot at my place and then this car pulls
up to me like hey man your your what are
your taillights is out wait are you no I
was like [ __ ] I'm like look man I don't
use those like the Cryptkeeper I'm so
sorry I look [ __ ] terrifying right
now you know that's because I had a
facial no just I looked [ __ ] horribly
a guy supposed to get facials guys
officials it's good for you don't you
get facial clear your pores out I need
something to get the sandpaper out of oh
my god let me do it please you know how
to do it I [ __ ] love how do you do it
like where it goes away completely
what's wrong with you it always comes
back videos Julia knows yeah who knows
what were you and you do Joseph I want
to watch no but like that you're not
supposed to use like the strips that
much because it will [ __ ] up your your
pores it stretches your pores out even
more employees cannot shrink it all what
I do I have like needle nose of tweezers
like just tiny ones and I pull them out
one by one and I can sit there for
[ __ ] hours man just go to sleep take
a nap by the time you wake up you're
gonna be beautiful I just got one that's
like a electric thing and then you go
yeah pretty better for you because it
breaks your capillaries oh yeah food
causes
coloration but you know I just don't do
the maintenance okay okay you could take
it so anyway my face is fine take my oil
children so there's this hospital that
turned down about three thousand dollars
from a fundraising group because the
group of men had been dressed as female
nurses and this hospital thought that
they were sexualizing and disrespecting
the profession and that's why they
turned it down stupid really wearing
like crop top well if they're wearing
like the stripper nurse outfit know what
it's like the Red Cross woman who cares
are they in need for a [ __ ] donation
or not I feel like it can come from like
[ __ ] like murder or robbery like [ __ ]
you take it they're dressed like that
one got some normal [ __ ]
they look [ __ ] cool I love don't hang
out you hate them that's awesome this
has been like an annual thing that this
group has been have been doing well
they've been doing it all the time so
they just decided this year I don't want
to do it so [ __ ] sensitive now like
you know you're objectifying women shut
the [ __ ] up take the money and save
people you look [ __ ] they're probably
saying like well what if they dressed up
as Chinese people would you like that
yes yeah I actually would mm-hmm show up
[ __ ] go ching chong whatever just
raise money I feel like if I had a
hospital you know uh it doesn't matter
where the money comes from money is not
moral money's just point eat it yeah so
it's like if it came from a strippers
[ __ ] I don't care you should work hard
for it yeah if it came from like the the
selling of guns to a warlord that that
kills children I would I don't care okay
that would you're saving a life
when this hospitals director is out
giving his speech we will not take the
$3,000 one guy in a hospital bed globe
like if you go up to a dying patient
said hey look we had the money to save
you we could have but
dealer money so sorry and the guys like
the guy hospice gonna be like my [ __ ]
you guys yeah do their money was like
arms dealers okay we had the money to
save you but pretty sure you've used
drug dealer money my gosh yeah probably
but I didn't know about it I'll open up
a hospital and I'll say look we take
everybody we save everybody
so no judgement here yeah yeah if you
ain't got the money and you get a [ __ ]
heart transplant it's cool we got Pablo
Escobar money it don't matter where the
money comes from we're saving live fine
that's that's all I need it cuz
hospitals job to be moral right I said
criminals comin with a gunshot wound
they still treat that yeah they're not
gonna be like what are you doing their
goal is to save lives
after a hundred percent call and a child
rapist came in they still it's barreled
their responsibility treat you real slow
they don't think about what they just
saved the life yeah gunshots butthole
wounds everything if that guy that I
save because he got shot by Pablo
Escobar's minions right if he comes back
as I hey I'd like to thank you here's
five million dollars for saving my life
I'll be like cool yeah thank you very
much
let me use it for good yeah yeah I'm
like an angel down I take the money from
the devils and then I make I use it for
good imagine wanted a dog if you wanted
the doggie sanctuary and then this guy
goes hey by the way I run a child
brothel in Thailand
oh man eight million dollars that's
different nam could have your doggie no
I don't want it at that boy she's a
little bit iffy yeah I got it for the
medical thing cuz like yous guys said
which I agree a hundred percent it's not
their duty to be morally correct it's
their duty to save life so that's their
Y that's the company vision I get it
it's a long eyes it's a huge yeah but
for something that's not in it like dog
sanctuary I'll find I'll find a
different means making it happen or you
could be like I'm down and then have
police track it back there you go you
build a relationship that's a kid get
enemies close around for years I can't
so emotional I can't do it let Bart do
it and then he'll call the cops they're
right you know we need the D team the
Dayton will come
what's the detail again B Squad what do
they do though me and Boris we save
mother save people and your boys raise
money for Sick Children so your money
and then you open up your dog farm and
then you hunt him down and then chop him
up into pieces and feed it to dogs what
I would do is so it is very widely known
that inmates hate pedophiles yep they
hate them so I first break into a jail
and then maybe gather up a hundred
inmates and then we go over to the child
brothel and then they murder everyone
that runs it and then afterwards I buy
everyone Carl's Judas with a happy and
then I take them back into the jail and
then I give them lots of cement so they
can cement the walls back up from the
inside out and lock themselves but I
think we should put it so you go to the
jail be like you know what animals
rehabilitate prisoners so let me take so
many prisoners pet the animals
rehabilitate and then send in the child
touch her
molestation and then put them in there
and just be like hey guys um
and just lock them all in the barn
together for like an hour the dog bites
his dick off yeah yeah yeah the
prisoners beat the sinners rape him I
like this idea you know I believe in
self-sustainability yeah and ecosystems
you know things got a like go full
circle right so you know don't put too
much energy in trying to solve the world
you gotta let you got kind of like work
it that way I like that idea so then the
animals get some play time some chew toy
a new chew toy oh yeah prisoners get
some you know like doggy toys I exercise
and they get to take out their anger on
a piece of [ __ ] yeah and the body gets
disposed because all the animals eat
them that's truly win-win-win everywhere
that's awesome
the punished dollar ever present Joe
Mallya punishment decider preserve you
are the nonprofit the Secretary of non
fraud nonprofit organization yeah I got
you I got this hey what's up guys thanks
for watching we are going to regularly
start posting content on the JK films
Instagram so make sure you follow us
there the last video click over here
[Music]